then have feared Hades the god of the
underworld for as long as we can
remember but what if we told you that
Hades wasn't actually a villain sure he
might have a bad reputation but that
doesn't necessarily make him a bad guy
before making any more assumptions let's
delve into his backstory and find out
the truth watch until the end to find
out why the Greek gods back story is the
most messed-up of all
we know Hades as the god of the
underworld that the ancient Greeks
referred to him as plutons the wealth
giver Romans also knew a thing or two
about Hades but they chose to call him
Pluto today many of us refer to Hades as
hell after all that is where he spends
most of his time the contrary to popular
belief Hades is far from being the
double ish creature we paint him out to
be Hades had two brothers Poseidon and
Zeus and they were made to divvy up the
world unfortunately for Hades he was
given the underworld whereas Zeus
received the heavens and beside in the
oceans unlike his brothers who grew up
to be praised and loved Hades was given
the short end of the stick but whether
or not he minded is up for debate as the
world under keeper Hades became a
dreaded commodity he was so greatly
feared that many refrained from speaking
his name or depicting him in art the
underworld was no place for a god still
someone had to balance the world of the
living in the dead as this ensured peace
and order on earth Greeks much preferred
to give thanks and praise to Poseidon
and Zeus in fact many of them referred
to Hades as the other Zeus which is
probably why the God wasn't too fond of
his brother despite having a deadly
reputation Hades could be reasoned with
till Hades has a valid reason for hating
Zeus but will disclose why a little
later spending eternity in the
underworld can get a little boring and
extremely lonely to say the least
so when Hades fell in love with
Persephone he decided to take her as his
wife if problem was
Hades resorted to kidnapping her instead
of courting her
still some might say that he had little
choice in the matter considering no one
ever wanted to journey to the underworld
unfortunately Hades job was so demanding
that the god only traveled above ground
on one or two occasions one of them
being Persephone's abduction one day
when Bruce F&E and her maidens were
picking flowers
Hades caused a beautiful flower to bloom
before her eyes Persephone was instantly
attracted to it she plucked it from the
ground and seconds later it opened up
beneath her and she fell through she was
soon greeted by Hades who was waiting
for her in a four-horse golden chariot
Hades now had a three-headed dog and a
beautiful wife and all of a sudden the
underworld didn't seem too bad of a
place regrettably Hades happiness wasn't
bound to last forever because well
Persephone's mother Demeter mourned her
appearance when Demeter found out what
had happened to her daughter she begged
the gods to retrieve her but her wish
was not granted the Greek gods begged
Demeter to come home but were unable to
persuade her so to save humankind Zeus
sent Hermes to the underworld to
compromise with its ruler
despite being branded as the bad guy
Hades complied to Demeter's demands but
not before making his wife eat a single
pomegranate seed this seed would ensure
that Persephone remained tied to the
underworld
this way she would be obliged to return
home for one third of the year still
whether or not Persephone truly loved
her husband is unknown there are many
who believe that Hades and Persephone
raised a family together but when you
take a little deeper you find out that
these gods did indeed have children just
not together
pd's is said to have a daughter named
Macario however no one knows whom
acharyas mother is and Persephone is
said to have a son named Zacharias with
Hades very own brother Zeus so there you
have it guys the real reason Zeus and
Hades don't get along stay tuned to find
out why descendants fans think that mal
and Macario are one in the same it's
easy to see Hades as the bad guy after
all he collects Souls kidnaps his love
interests and spends most of his time
underground still there's a method to
his madness all-in-all Hades doesn't
take pleasure in his work it's not the
job he chose for himself but rather the
one he was given and balancing the world
of the living and the dead needs to be
done Hades has spent his entire life
living in his brother's shadow so it's
no big surprise that he dislikes them as
much as they just like him on top of
that the only woman Hades ever truly
loved agreed to spend two thirds of the
year away from him only to later become
pregnant with his brother's child
although it stated that a tease seldom
left the underworld it's possible that
this is far from the truth after all
Hades created an invisibility helmet
which allowed him to travel without
being seen Hades we know and love is
often portrayed as a miserable character
and well this wouldn't be too far from
the truth since spending centuries in
the dark underworld did do something to
his mind over time Hades began to enjoy
evoking fear which is what led him to
develop a sarcastic and morbid
personality being the god of the
underworld can give you a
at reputation but truth be told 80s was
not the one responsible for sending
mortals to hell instead he was the one
tasked with welcoming them it was then a
toast the god of death who would judge
in charge mortals who had committed
unforgivable crimes still Hades was so
scary that he became known as the devil
when in truth he was an extremely just
God who often times showed mercy all in
all it's safe to say that Hades is
simply misunderstood he's just a ruler
who has a bad reputation due to his
terrifying outlook now that we know how
the Greeks depicted Hades let's take a
look at how Hades was portrayed in the
classic Disney film Hercules since many
of us watch Disney movies before ever
learning about Creake mythology it's
safe to say that we first met Hades in
1997 when Disney released Hercules as a
result we were initially led to believe
that Hades aka the god of the underworld
was one of the evilest beings in the
entire world fortunately this isn't
exactly true but let's entertain the
notion in Disney's Hercules Hades wants
nothing more than to usurp his brother's
Zeus's throne and take over Mount
Olympus he truly believes he's earned
this platform seeing as he spent
centuries underground Disney chose to
give Hades a tantalizing attitude the
God was clearly intelligent and
conniving but he was also hilarious and
merciful choosing to strike deals with
people instead of condemning them in
Greek mythology Hades enjoys being the
god of the underworld and he accepts his
role without complaint
but in Hercules it's Zeus who gives
Hades the underworld despite him wanting
nothing to do with it since Hades has a
fun and sarcastic personality it's easy
to see why living in the underworld just
isn't his style Disney's Hades hates his
job and everything that comes along with
it he wants to be soaking up the Sun on
Mount Olympus but it's forbidden to do
so so this is precisely why Hades wants
to take his brother Zeus out of the
picture and rule instead problem is Zeus
is stronger than Hades will ever be so
fighting him on his own is simply out of
the question with this in mind
Zeus tends to team up with unlikely
forces to challenge his brother's title
whereas Hades the unseen enjoy
having his three-headed dog Cerberus by
his side this isn't the case for the
Disney villain version instead hades is
often seen with his shape-shifting
lackeys pain and panic despite being
known for his intelligence Hades often
puts his trust in pain and panic which
has proven to be a horrible idea in the
past in Hercules Hades consults the
fates to find out it's all be victorious
in conquering Mount Olympus they
confirmed that he will in 18 years time
when the planets align on this fateful
day Hades will be able to unleash the
Titans which Zeus previously imprisoned
and take over his brother's throne the
fates go on to say that his plans will
be foiled if Hercules son of Zeus
intervenes so this causes Hades to send
pain and panic to poison his nephew with
a very special potion the potion will
turn Hercules into a normal baby human
thus allowing Hades to get rid of him
once and for all
fortunately pain and panic do not
succeed in giving Hercules every last
drop of the potion and he grows up to be
extremely strong and mighty
so despite Haiti's best efforts the
prophecy takes place and Hades misses
his window
although Hades might be the main
antagonist of the movie he's managed to
remain as one of the most favored Disney
villains of all time
all in all Disney's Hades is relatable
and hilarious this misunderstood Greek
god has been driven to madness and many
would argue that he isn't as bad as he
seems as many of you know Disney Channel
is currently working on releasing
descendants 3 which will showcase Hades
in a very off-beat way Millennials are
so used to seeing Hades in a negative
light that it's hard for them to imagine
him being a good guy but from the looks
of it Hades might end up helping auradon
be that as it may it's very possible
that Hades is merely helping auradon to
save his own skin but will judge him
once the truth gets out when King the
East and Queen Belle became the rulers
of auradon they chose to bring the
villains back to life and imprison them
on the Isle of the laws Hades is one of
these villains so it's safe to say that
he's no longer ruling over the
underworld or scheming to take over
Mount Olympus
oddly enough however Hades has never
been seen before so it's possible that
the villain was so evil
that he had to be locked up in a jail
cell on the aisle this is clearly
demonstrated in the trailer when we see
Celia opening up an iron door to release
the blue-haired God many descendants
fans believe Hades to be mouths father
after all she did refer to a blue orb as
dad in under the sea a descendent story
and since Hades is one of the newest
additions to the descendants franchise
fans are convinced that there's more to
his story than meets the eye
oddly enough Hades did have a daughter
named Macario and while we believe her
mother to be Persephone some sources
state that no one knows who her mother
truly is she's described as having black
hair and violet eyes and she's often
pictured wearing dark purples and greens
we don't know about you but this sounds
like a lot like mal to us still there's
a reason why Maleficent doesn't want her
daughter knowing who her father is
because well if a tease truly is her dad
this would make mal a demigod and since
Maleficent didn't want her daughter
knowing she was stronger than her this
may be why she chose to leave her in the
dark Disney's Hercules portrays Hades as
a gray skinned villain who has yellow
eyes a long face and flaming blue hair
he's short-tempered witty and bitter but
he's an honest God who always holds up
his end of the bargain he's often seen
wearing black robes that are tied
together with a silver skull pin going
from a cartoon to a real-life human can
be quite the jump which is why it's only
normal that actor Cheyenne Jackson looks
nothing like Disney's first adaptation
of the villain the Disney Channel has
managed to stay true to Hades essence
choosing to stick with the blue hair
wicked smile and black clothing still
ladies looks a lot more fashionable than
ever before do you think Hades will
prove himself useful and help the v-j
save auradon or is Hades truly as rotten
as they say he is the villain might
actually prove himself to be genuine and
kind however if they choose to base
Hades off of his Disney movie
counterpart auradon might be dealing
with their biggest threat yet so is
Hades a misunderstood Greek god or a
wicked and calculating villains let us
know what your verdict is in the
comments section below
give this video a big thumbs up if
you've been Katie's backstory
is seriously messed up and while you're
at it be sure to subscribe to the things
for the latest Disney news thanks for
watching we'll see you soon
[Music]